your your dad is the CEO but the mom is
the CEO I think it's a very good analogy
right there whereas like you've heard
that the man is the head but the woman
is the neck all these types of things
but I want to I want to I want to relate
that into money at this point let's have
a little money conversation
men are traditionally the provider The
Breadwinner you just use the term uh
provider in a second but now according
to NPR thirty percent of wives now out
earn their husbands so a question thirty
percent thirty percent so when a woman
out earns her husband how do you think
that affects the power dynamic in a
relationship uh sorry yeah yeah I
thought you're gonna keep going no go
okay no I I mean typically I don't think
like women day up I think typically it's
it's not good that doesn't end well
um I would say what I've heard um Auntie
my BFF shout out Auntie
um she says that in those situations
it's better to let the man handle the
money she's like you'll trust a man with
your body but not your money
so you're recommending that the woman
even if she owns earns the husband to
give the money to her man to to manage I
would yeah okay yeah that's what I would
do let me tell you something yeah let me
let me give let me give a pro a shout
out real quick whatever dude actually I
ends up wiping you up
you're gonna give them whatever you're
gonna give him the money he doesn't have
to get married legally he's gonna you're
gonna be the follower he's going to be
the leader
uh am I is that a fair statement like
you're ready just to comply and commit
uh and to your husbands yeah yeah all
right I mean submit I meant submit I'm
all about it I begged my dad I make I
make my dad manage my money you know
it's funny
I'm 26. I do have a question so if you
say you were in that situation and you
would give the man your money to manage
I mean at home no sorry if he's like an
at-home dad why would you feel
comfortable to give a man who doesn't
earn that money to manage an at-home dad
I usually date guys with like jobs right
but I'm just saying like for that
situation like you said right like the
woman made all the money and she gave
the man the money to manage like I find
it a little bit hard for like
a lot of average women to feel confident
to give a man all the money when he
hasn't worked for it nor like get
educational what to do with it if that
makes sense oh I mean that's why again I
don't give advice I don't say that's for
everyone but um I mean just in general
women spend more anyways probably going
to be better with the money than you are
I mean women make 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions even though we make
less money right I mean I can understand
why a woman would just to like get rid
of the headache but like for me I I mean
I could understand why a woman would
hesitate to just you know just give away
all that money especially after like
women probably like died around well
that's why like I just think of the
relationship with my like I trust my dad
so much like I would hope I would be
with someone I trust them you know what
I mean no yeah but I would just think
like my parents always had a joint bank
account anyway yeah and then it's like
who makes the financial dislike to me
they just had one I'm gonna do your
favor okay whatever you make all your
YouTube stuff all your money
I'm just saying save that money uh
in general Hafiz what percentage should
the man pay for in a marriage or even in
a long-term relationship and what
percentage should a woman pay for that's
a hard question because
um I believe if Natalia wants to put the
data I believe
almost 60 percent of married women work
right so they're working for a reason
they're paying a bill right so a
majority of women married women are
working so they're paying a bill and and
a traditional sense and my motto men pay
it all right but I'm not as naive to
realize that not every single man can be
able to afford to pay all the bills I
don't want to I don't want to belittle a
man who's a teacher who's not able to
pay you know the fullness of his family
so in my opinion a man can still lead
without making the most money and so
that's just something I think the answer
hope that answers your question because
percentage it matters like it depends
right if you're a guy and let's say your
purpose in life is to be a fifth grade
teacher that's your purpose in life
right and then all of a sudden you're
dating a woman who's a teacher then she
becomes a principal now all of a sudden
she's making more right so you can still
be the leader the masculine dominant
leader in your home though she's making
more is there going to be challenges a
hundred thousand but a man can still
leave though he's not making all the
money does a girl work excuse me no she
doesn't work okay so you take care of
what percentage of the bills okay and
does that work for large expenses and
small expenses
reading okay so large expenses uh I'm
paying the rent I'm paying the car bills
I mean I'm paying the bills I'm paying
the utilities I'm paying the health
insurance bigger bills but you're also
taking care of like nails hair clothing
that gets annoying doesn't it well
here's a reality like I said every man
needs to understand who you're marrying
if if I was dating a girl who has a
three thousand dollar hair and nail
budget best believe I will never marry
that woman you know what I mean like
that's why like I said is you have to be
wise enough to realize you know is she a
spender is she a saver what is her
standard of living what is her
expectation all these things that you
gotta really investigate through pre
pre-engagement counseling really
investigate by using your wisdom and
discernment use your parents look at her
parents it's it takes a lot of
investigation and if she's an individual
who's who knows how to save that money
and smart with money you're not going to
have those bills respect and if you're
thinking marriage like you're treating
it like a unit like you're one and that
so I don't understand like and if he's
making the decisions like I feel like
you should be able to trust him with
that well here fair enough respect
[Music]
um
I hear conflicting that maybe you have
stats on this this is just I'm gonna
throw this out there you guys pick this
up from where on one hand I hear men
lead women follow the men pay the bills
women you know give the man the money
you know a woman shouldn't have to work
like in this situation and on the other
hand I hear a dual like you got to have
like dual incomes just to get by so I
guess what I'm saying is this there's a
lot of people are like no the woman
needs to work in order to us to make a
hundred thousand dollars so we can
survive because I make 60 and she makes
40 we make 50 make 50. on the other hand
I hear a lot of stories about it's
actually lost opportunity cost by the
fact that she's going out making 40
Grand or if she would just stay home
with the kids take care cook maybe even
homeschooling or whatever not we don't
need that 40 Grand because it's better
served to save that money and keep her
in the house and we don't need their
income and could you save anyone else do
you have any thoughts on what these
conflicting things we're going to do an
episode of wife school on this like a
lot of times women want a lifestyle more
than like they can really get in a guy
and so it's like a lot of times it's
about the lifestyle you when you go down
to it I was talking to this woman she
like married a guy that makes six
figures she doesn't work and she said
she keeps her expenses under
can't remember what it was it was like
ten thousand dollars a year for like 10
kids because they just live super
freaking I'm not saying like everybody
can do that and it depends on where you
live but I think a lot of times like
women want a lifestyle that they can't
afford like they want to eat out they
want to buy clothes every month like
they don't go down to like the actual
Necessities well I feel like that is
common and in America in general men and
women
um no I mean women this is just more
anecdotal like just from come on women
spend more than men do like like I see
more women with like hair extensions
fake lashes like all the stuff that I
see men in luxury suits oh facts yeah
and so when you say who who's who's more
addicted to the lifestyle women
so what was your question Adam yes so so
I'm saying like I asked this question on
my show all the time would you go in
life down in lifestyle for a family and
our girls say hell no hell no and I just
think that a lot of times is the problem
yeah I I also think that social media
has a large part of it like I saw I
don't know forgive me I don't know if it
was on fresh and fit or or Rollo showed
he does with uh my buddy Michael certain
I forget what it was uh and they went I
think it was on pressure fit and they
went around and they asked a group of
women and they said would you rather a
boyfriend or Instagram
and they all went around they're like
give me the gram hook me up with a gram
IG baby because all the attention that
they're getting and the opportunity and
whatever like obviously these girls are
only fans type girls and and these types
of situations and they all chose the
gram not a man yes and that's kind of
indicative of what your study of society
with his lifestyle and everything that
kind of comes with that and and I know
you said that you're not traditional but
in essence you kind of are I mean I
would say I'm a modern woman I have some
Traditional Values but again like I
think all women in 2022 have been
influenced to some extent by feminism
like you know in my like I used to be
obsessed with bot like that was the only
thing I cared about volleyball
volleyball volleyball and I just think
on some level like everyone's been
influenced a little bit it's hard to
find traditional women in 2022. yeah
it's tough out there like a girl with
their own cookbook I just started one
but I don't you know I I haven't
finished it yet probably things cookbook
yeah come anyway
um I I want to ask us another question
so
um with that being said with this only
only fans culture and women being able
to monetize their sex and you know as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible